suck a happy birthday thank you very
much and thank you to everybody who uh
wrote to me how old are you today i'm
27. 20 [ __ ] seven years old what were
you doing when you were 27 years old
could you shut your cell phone up first
that do you know who that is that's the
third of my jew circle that's hari
shafir
that's the third so see oh i'm telling
you i'm jewish in spirit by the way on
an ari shafir show yo i got my man bobby
slayton in studio i'll call you when i
get up wait wait wait wait are you
talking to the [ __ ] wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait this is a jewish
[ __ ] reunion here ask will you ask
him a question while i'm i'll ask him
right now what is that esquire's never
had me on his own tell me he's never had
you on the storytellers show
bobby slayton
all right he set the showcase on july
18th in the belly room
i'll call you when i get out of here
[ __ ] no i'm doing august uh 18th
all right i'll call you later
bye buddy maybe i should leave my phone
on it gives my wife calls maybe need
something from ralph's on my way home
maybe so
well you know you know i walked you know
i was very excited about doing your show
and i still am by the way but you know
and and by the way you could not have it
in a more
in a perfect place for joey d as the
cuban i come in here you're above a chop
shop there are these clandestine little
officers next door where the hookers and
every guy goes what people don't do with
these offices but i don't even care no
name there's no numbers on the doors i
love this here more sugar it's like
hollywood babylon it's like the locust
this is it listen we were going to get a
[ __ ] offer somewhere remember it was
like 1200 a month when you look and a
view and then people know who the [ __ ]
you are and when your producer the boy
wonder said and you said to me you look
when you pull up uh you know there's no
parking in front let me let my producer
come out and get you the birthday boy
and then he pulls me around back we'll
go through this gated thing with stolen
cars and it really felt like it was
getting set up was like a miami flight
stickers
i give you the full [ __ ] ambiance
bobby slater and then i walk in with the
shittiest popcorn that pop popcorn
there's 350. that's great pop that's
what if you like
makes a medical cannabis [ __ ] white
cheddar popcorn
i'm telling you i haven't eaten an
edible like a week i'm [ __ ] up you
know have you really not yes this last
wednesday i don't think i did what have
you been doing right
[ __ ] you know it's funny i know that
you know ari shafir i knew you rogan
that you guys love pot you guys love pot
the way that when i was in high school i
loved pot something happened over the
years and i've talked to other people
bill maher loves party when i was in
high school i think it was 14 years old
1969 that's when i first got turned down
to marijuana and it was uh you know the
end of the hippie era but it was still
it's marijuana i mean it's like an
illicit thing you're 14. and by the time
i was 15 or 16 i couldn't get through a
day of school god forbid to go to a
yankee game or a concert at the academy
of music i mean they had to go to a
movie without pot make it through i mean
i would scrape resin remember do that
scrape resin out of a out of a hash pipe
smoke seeds and stems of anything they
even simulate getting high and then all
of a sudden when i hit my early 20s and
blow took over from there and alcohol i
mean it was like those things but for
some reason pot you know my body started
making sun make me really paranoid i
know everybody you guys smoking relax
you i started getting up tight thinking
about all my problems we stuff up my
sinuses unlike blow because my body
works in mysterious ways i do a line i'd
relax maybe it's like riddling for a
hyperactive add you know kid but i it
would clear my sinuses out it would be
the exact opposite what pot should be
doing to me coke did for me
so everybody once every six months i
decide i'm hanging out with a guy like
you or you know i'm in montreal or
something i'll take a hit a pot well
maybe maybe this is better part than
what i had maybe i've changed way like
looking why i used to hate broccoli and
brussels sprouts maybe to be a whole
awakening now i love pot brussels bro
and i smoke a joint or my daughter's
boyfriend would come over and i realized
that now the part when we thought we
were getting great stuff back in the old
days in a pecos acapulco gold that's
garbage compared to what they're making
now so all you need is a hit of that
[ __ ] as you know and you are [ __ ]
[ __ ] lying flying flying man they had
acapulco gold at the weed store where i
go yeah like what is that because it was
expensive weed for that store right and
i go let me see that it smell like dick
people have no idea how them are red
panama that was a big early 70s pecos
you know this and then of course thai
stick which is steady artist now again i
see i don't remember pecos i came around
when it was
like uh it wasn't a regular weed yeah
then i had a buddy used to get gold weed
right and we paid a nickel bag back then
right but for gold wheels like 20 bucks
if you paid 20 bucks
a fortune people don't know oh my god
much money and it was cd yeah and you'd
only get like four joints right did
names actually mean something when they
were dealing yes alcohol gold it was
kind of my red was like a reddish brown
weed that [ __ ] you up yeah and then
you had thai stick which is a weed that
was put on a stick and it was rolled
with a twine right and you could smell
it from a [ __ ] oh geez now pot
you can smell from 10 miles away and
it's twice as good as that stuff i used
to i remember like how the uh you know
when i was like 16 i smoked regular
stuff and then a buddy of mine that
worked at levy's sporting goods used to
get chocolate thai wheat and we used to
call it chocolate traumatized
because it would traumatize really would
you forgot [ __ ] you lost your money
and then i had another i had a teacher
in high school who was in charge of
building the sets for plays yep
and if you were part of that they gave
you 15 credits per school year because
you worked on with your hands and built
[ __ ] it's a lot of credits but at the
time that dumb [ __ ] was getting
orders from people and he would get
weeds sent up from hawaii and again we
were paying five dollars
gold was 20 bucks this [ __ ] was like 35
right right right and it was tremendous
you know the first time i tried the real
pharmaceutical stuff i went into one of
those places because as you know you
can't go back there and look at the
goods unless you have a prescription so
a couple years ago two three years ago
my wife had shingles which i hear now is
the most painful horrible thing and she
tried everything and she tried every
kind of painkiller she tried everything
everybody recommended i'll take this and
try the homeopathic and try the nothing
worked so a friend of mine said listen
you know i hear if you get some hash oil
they make a kind now a friend of mine
had shingles you get this hash oil
doesn't get you high because there are
different strengths
which i still could you have to sativa
you get the indigo yeah i never knew how
that worked but i guess it's like how
advil and esper knows what part of the
body to go to right thinking oh paul
ryan i'm doing here anyway so i take her
down she gets a prescription which is so
easy to get and uh so she goes in the
guy gives her some oil goes you're not
getting high from this because my wife's
like me she doesn't really like what it
does to her and she took some of the oil
and just a couple of drops and it didn't
really help her much but she got stoned
out of her mind for two days and hated
it i go what up [ __ ] let me try this
stuff and i tried it and you know what i
got a little buzz but it wasn't really i
didn't like it at all either so about a
month ago i'm in denver you know
colorado where anybody could walk in
like a candy store and go buy something
i said you know even though i don't
smoke this anymore i gotta go go i gotta
go in i gotta for old but i gotta get
some for old time's sake and i went and
i said to the guy look i don't really
like getting stoned anymore i explained
to him everything i just told you but i
hear that there's you know a strain you
could buy the indigo whatever indica and
i said you can get it i said i like to
relax because i get the metabolism of a
hummingbird so for 15 bucks he goes
smoke one of these because you probably
don't even need the whole thing it'll
relax you it'll be great so i go back to
my hotel and i lit the joint and i took
a couple of hits and nothing happened
and it took a couple of more hits then i
go well okay i'm a little relaxed and
then i thought you know what this is not
good this is like my you know cutting
the hair of samson this is like throwing
water in the wicked witch if i start to
relax my comedy shots will be gone you
know i won't i won't get mad at somebody
that doesn't make a right turn on the
red light i won't be pissed at people i
would and i and i said you know what
vodka will do the same thing i don't
need this [ __ ] i should have brought it
for you because you probably could next
time i come to do your your podcast next
year and by the way let me tell you
something else you've been doing this
for a year here and now you finally have
me on what no we talked we talked a
couple months ago and you said you were
leaving after before the stones we spoke
and you said yeah leaving for six weeks
you leave on wednesday so yeah so the
other day when i got the call to
audition i saw barry levinson right so
let me call this guy but i forgot to
tell you on the phone now
and it all worked out you were in town
you know usually you leave on mondays or
tuesday you have a [ __ ] up schedule
yeah no i'm always here now now that i'm
doing so great so far the first 10
minutes i'll be a regular i've invited
myself to become a regular now
do you have a lot of work now bobby are
you still going out every week hey joey
joey joey uh
you know
it's brutal out there if you're not on
television you know that well you know
what it's like we've talked about that
so many times you know and it doesn't
matter how funny you are if you're not
putting answers in the seats you know
and it's tough now because like i'm i
just turned 60 years old and yes i know
how great i look
your birthday boy what are you 27 yeah
you look like you have aids and cancer
and ebola and and shingles and you just
get back
all at once you look horrible and uh
um you were born when he was 33 years
old yeah yeah but you imagine that you
were born i think i think i just got
married at 33. 33.0032 my wife is 33
which in a way seems like a lifetime ago
and in a way it seems like yesterday you
know what i mean you have a 27 year old
daughter 27 year old daughter and we
married married for 27 28 years
coincidence perhaps you know and that
was kind of a you know my wife got
pregnant and i said she didn't really
want to have an abortion and we didn't
really want to have a kid and you know i
you know it's one of those things where
we we look i i think i said to her look
we're going to get married anyway we're
going to have a kid someday and
abortion's a horrible thing you know so
let's just have the kid you know let's
just get married and we did it and
i wish we didn't do it we had the
abortion i'd be happy right now but
i have to i need a drink no i but you
know things over there no it worked out
fine you're very tight with your
daughter uh
not as tight as i used to be you know i
feel not to be as tight now you know
it's tough you know i mean you'll see
when your kid grows up you i see it now
she's two and a half and she throws me
out of her [ __ ] room yeah no she
doesn't she does what does she do daddy
you know you know daddy bye bye she'll
come get me sit with me make me sit and
watch a couple of those [ __ ]
halloween it's halloween night not a
soul in sight i hear footsteps who's
that coming i watch like 10 of those
and then she'll tell you she'll tell me
to get up and there's a pillow i lay on
she takes the pillow and puts in her
[ __ ] crib
by herself and she goes daddy bye bye my
wife picks her up and then i'll come in
10 minutes later and i ask her for a
kiss and sometimes she'll give it to me
and sometimes she'll go bye-bye get the
[ __ ] out of it that's just the bread
that's a woman
it just eats you up alive but another
time she comes and gets me by the finger
come
and she and she as she's pulling me she
goes pull pull so you know what i mean
you know what i bet you're seeing it is
i don't mean to do material on your show
but i did turn it into a bit because
it's absolutely true and i see it more
than ever i see it all the time it's
when your kid does something
really [ __ ] up your wife will say i'm
sure again where do you think she gets
that from where do you think she gets
that language from where do you think
she gets it but anytime the kid anybody
compliments the kid that guy she got my
looks and my brains you the women can't
wait to take credit for everything the
kid does is right when the kid has
something screwed up you know what she's
very selfish where do you think she gets
that from you it's always your fault as
a father and it's when the kid does
something right you know i my daughter
i'm not making this up i think she had a
speeding ticket when she was 16. she had
a driver's license for a week my wife
says to me that's from your side of the
family like it's not diabetes it's a
speedy ticket it doesn't run in my
family but they can't wait to put the
blame on you you know for everything and
that's the way
because i remember when i used to go to
the house you were very tight with her
you know i could see that yeah her world
you know she was 20 and she would giggle
and we would talk about anything in
front of her yeah she's not like that i
mean that's what a kid i want to talk
about anything in front of her right i
just don't want to go to daycare and
saying suck my dick at this point right
three years old i don't have my daughter
saying it you know my daughter when she
was little i would
i would let her watch my show but she'd
sit in the back room with a babysitter
maybe she was seven or eight she could
sit by herself with a coloring book but
you know she'd hear things or she'd
sneak out and just listen for a minute
and
you know
how come he's a picture you know maybe
we're saying what do you well i came out
to use the bathroom daddy and i heard
you saying nothing about my but you know
what she was she and then people would
say to me aren't you embarrassed that
isn't it said that your daughter can't
see your your act because no not at all
because i remember steven spielberg
jurassic park came out his kid was like
eight or nine and he said i wouldn't let
my kids see the movie you know just
because you have a kid doesn't mean you
should be able to let them see whatever
you do because there's certain things
that are made for adults you know i
really don't want her to know i do stand
up to she has nothing to say that's an
embarrassment i don't want her to know
there'd be no way for you to like like
if you were gonna be like okay i have to
do something that mercy could watch
you'd have to change your entire
way
why would you not i don't want i don't
know i do stuff
why is that just some until she's so she
understands what the whole concept is
right you know until she understands the
concept and
i i was you know bobby slatten people
like you and i would when we were 10 we
were already 20. right and we right blue
you look back right you know i didn't
play [ __ ] operation right did i tell
you my wife played what battleship so i
can learn how to play [ __ ] battles
right because at 10 i was running
numbers i didn't have time for [ __ ]
battleships you know you know i knew
what [ __ ] was i knew what sucking was
i knew what cocaine was and it was great
it was great no my mother raised me so
nobody could pull the blanket over my
eyes but it took away my childhood you
know it's funny because you mentioned
you and i and i gotta you know what i
always seem because people always i'm
born in the bronx but i grew up in west
chester with the rich jews okay i i
gotta say
that when i was 10 i wasn't i led a
sheltered you know you're going to get
bar mitzvahed i'm not saying i liked any
of this you know played
by the time i was maybe 16 or 17 because
i wasn't a street kid and i wasn't grown
up the bronx and i played on a manicured
lawn and i didn't play stickball in the
bronx and i was but you know by the time
i was 16 or 17 and when i finally ate it
and i moved out to california i mean it
took it took me a while you know there
were a lot of kids a lot of comics if
you're watching me you could tell the
guys that came from a background where
they did stuff you know i didn't do
stuff as early as you i wasn't running
the numbers at 10. but i've run away
from moment 14. i was smoking dope and
you know doing coke at 15. i mean but
not that that makes you into a man but i
was going to yankee stadium when i was
11. i was on the subway i was doing
stuff and but there were a lot of kids
and you know and you could see this in
certain comedians they didn't have they
had a nice childhood and they played
college football and they married their
high school sweetheart and you know they
didn't smoke dope till we were 30. they
still like journey they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway whatever i'm just saying
you could see the guys that were really
the collegiate straight ass no soul in
their stand-up because they don't have
the old souls my daughter was one of
those kids that you know you try to
raise them so by the time she was seven
eight years old she knew who the
supremes were she knew the difference
between ronnie spector and and and and
and and and uh you know maybe um you
know darlene love not that that makes
any difference but that's when i was
seven i was listening to the final
all-stars right when i was seven i was
listening to adult [ __ ] music i would
go to the kids house and they would
listen to the [ __ ] chipmunks
and i go what the [ __ ] are you listening
to the chipmunks and i go what you don't
have james brown you see i was listening
to that that's why i took a couple extra
years to say i got to get i got to put
that [ __ ] behind me so when i was about
17 i started doing the catch-up i said i
got to get to the apollo theater in new
york you know i got to my mother would
let me go to woodstock i got to go to
try to see hendricks i got to make up i
was i was i was listening to the
chipmunks at 10. but you also took her
to the punch line at eight
and that showed her that different world
oh absolutely and that's i'm i'm like
some of my wife we were talking she goes
so let me ask you this would you take
mercy
to 135th street when she was seven and
let her play without her godmother in
the street
i i don't know yeah you don't know i
don't know right if back in 1973 when
everybody connected on the block
everybody was puerto rican they all
worked together i hate that mcfuck i
hate those jews but at the end of the
day your kid played with my kid would
play with it skin yeah so we had to like
each other so if your kid was walking
with my kid even though i didn't like
[ __ ] jews i still waved at your boy
right and vice versa absolutely so yeah
in 1973 i'd leave mercy and go emerson
pick you up before play with these girls
here on the sidewalk i want you to see
what a junkie looks like no you can't no
i don't think you know what you know
what i remember how it started giving me
[ __ ] when um
the one reason to never have to be back
on the show anymore when my daughter got
into show business okay that's a touchy
thing that parents
um don't i mean if you saw right now
that your little girl was like a shirley
temple which every parent thinks their
kid is if you saw this incredible talent
in your little girl and she was tap
dancers like sammy davis at four and she
was singing and
were you and she said daddy i really
want to be an actress would you let her
do it at five six years old would you
take her to an audition and see how it
worked out because you know what i did
that i did it and and it worked out fine
for me because my daughter you know you
always hear about the the cases of the
kids who become these little drug
addicts and these old prima donnas these
little lindsay lohan's and they're a
[ __ ] train wreck by the time they're
18. but you got to remember something
there's hundreds of kids that got into
showbiz the ronnie howards or the kids
that said you know what i saved them for
money for college i want to become a
doctor or an architect there's those
kids too but it's almost like fourth of
july weekend you only hear about the
people that slipped in the bathtub
because they were drunk or got into a
boating accident you know you heard
about the 10 000 people that took a boat
out on the lake and had a barbecue and
had a nice time i was in bed by 11. it's
all it's all about the parents like i've
heard stories the college i go to has an
l.a program out here and they all live
in an apartment complex called the oak
woods oh yeah temporary housing they all
do that yeah so apparently
there's just these families of people
who go and stay in places like that like
temporary housing and are just taking
their kids around from
addition to audition if like it's
horrendous i didn't want to be an actor
at all but like let's say i did and my
parents ordered my parents out here
i wouldn't have done been doing coke i
don't think or or i don't think i would
have turned into a child star
but i think if you're the type of parent
who's gonna
uproot your kid for six months for pilot
season then maybe oh you know what
we saw that a lot when my daughter was
little okay she had this it seemed like
she wanted it you know
she was a clown and you show up if you
look at my home movies when i was two
i'm doing the twist and pulling down my
pants and push my brother out of the
camera so my father could do the eight
millimeter movies so when my daughter
was about two or three we got in one of
the top agents here in the valley and uh
i knew the woman for a long time and
natasha was very precocious and
beautiful my wife takes on a coke
commercial and she got a call back
immediately and what's going through my
head not not money for me i'm not one of
those parents but not that jackie you
know coogan thing but i'm thinking you
know what she'll have money for college
she'll she'll have the freedom to do
something unlike me who's trapped in
this business because i got no money so
she went back for the second audition
and she grabbed my wife's legs and goes
i don't want to do it i don't want to do
it that was the end of it that was the
end of it and i don't know if i ever
told you the story she's nine years old
and tomorrow is doing a show on the wb
network at universal studios and it was
uh uh jackie what jackie no he had a
show called the tom arnold show i think
it was the second show ed mcmahon was on
it um uh michael rosenbloom or michael
rosenberg went out to play superboy or
lex luthor in the superman show um
gene simmons wife what's her name uh she
was in it uh uh shana tweed
anyway there were two little girls on
the show and natasha would come to the
set you know friday we shoot the show
and she'd come to all the tapings and
she would love to go to the tapings
universal studios and she would hang out
with these little girls said daddy i got
to try this again i want to be a show
business i want to be an actress and i
said to my wife let's give it a try
she's not going to get anything she's
going to find out how frustrating this
is it'll give her some moral backbone
it'll give her you know the rejection
whatever and this is a good thing it's a
good lesson in life and if she does get
something more power to it let's see how
it works out my wife was had some
trepidation about this but i took her an
audition her third third edition she has
a 15 animated uh series uh called lion
hearts with uh perry gilpin and uh macy
bill macy what's his name yeah and she
gets that she does the animated show
about a month later she gets a series on
abc called brothers keeper they brought
it back for seven auditions because they
go wait a second we can't give this kid
she doesn't have any credits she doesn't
know what she's doing but she was
perfect for this part it was like it was
written for my daughter seven auditions
and she went backstreet for the network
she went for the producer she read for
everybody you know you know what a grind
it could be it's a [ __ ] ball buster i
don't want to put her through this but
she's she didn't seem like she really
cared that much you know what i mean so
she matured mature that's a different
game she matured and it wasn't a
desperation and we weren't those oakwood
parents who uprooted the kids from
kansas city because you better get this
you might have to be good we're going to
go back to kansas you know we think she
gets it she gets it she got the part on
a series she became a serious regular
but this is the kicker when her series
got on the tom arnold show gets
cancelled her show goes on the exact
same sound stage at universal studios
that the tom arnold show was now i was
only a recurring character so i was on
maybe five episodes out of the year so
my dressing room was one of those little
portable toilets in the parking lot with
the with the cleaning women the
janitorial supplies and the extras i had
to walk a mile and take the [ __ ] tram
to get she because she's a regular on
the show a giant parking space adjacent
to the set with a shower a parking space
with her name on it she's nine now when
i'm talking to you about you know the
fact that you shouldn't have an attitude
she gets a show she's getting whatever a
kid's getting back then 10 grand a week
which is god knows a lot of money and
she didn't tell anybody she went to
school and when she was uh she was a
good she went when she they were working
she had a teacher on this set and they
said your daughter's so nice she's so
kind she does her homework she did her
lines she knew and people would say to
me how about your daughter being shown
but it's like a week but she'd go to
school and very few of her friends she
would they knew she was on a show she
didn't make a big deal about it her
friends didn't make a big deal about it
she didn't tell anybody
so i mean if that's the way your kid can
go through showbiz not like i'm better
than you my [ __ ] doesn't stink you know
i'm a star there was none of that and if
there was i like to think my wife and i
would have pulled her from the uh or at
least stolen her money well i'm going to
tell you my reasons
i'm sick and tired of going anywhere in
studio city which i'm pardon the french
i'm explaining something to you about
studio city residents and pardon the
friends they're white [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay they're white [ __ ] there's no
money in studio city in their mind you
don't like saying white no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no it's [ __ ] okay sorry and
i don't mean that that's just an
expression
and then you're the dragon they call
them yellow [ __ ] remember when he goes
i can't believe behind our back they
call us yellow [ __ ] so
these are people listen when you go to
beverly hills and you go to what's the
street i got to go down your block to go
to your house then oh well beverly
glenn yeah and you see those houses
that's the money those are the people
have been directors for 50 [ __ ] years
or there are arabs that moved in and
taken malibu you know charlie sheens
where the super boy lives right you know
close to where rogan lives rogan lives
up dead and you go down those are people
in this town that have money studio city
is a place that's very gluten free
it's people who have been on a cv series
i like i like students i like it too
it's very gentile here's what i don't
like about it extra wow that i go to get
coffee and there's a woman who pulls up
and double parks doesn't let nobody in
nobody out in double parks a couple
who's 20 ahead of her she's in there
with her yoga pants she's talking loud
right you know and you look at that lady
and go her husband's never smacked her
in the [ __ ] mouth one time or called
her a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's why she's
acting this way and the husband's
probably banging his receptionist in the
office he just gives his wife money and
tells her yeah do what the [ __ ] you want
cause i'm getting my dick sucked anyway
i don't like
this is why i don't want to tell my
daughter what i do i went to uh
everybody has a weird attitude when
their husbands or their dads or
somebody's involved in show business you
were very lucky because your daughter
didn't have that she grew up watching me
and my wife and i were always
i was always very professional about it
and i never maybe because i didn't keep
trying to start but they never people
are [ __ ] pukes out here yeah they're
[ __ ] pukes in studio city so
i go to do an audition on ventura years
ago still is there's a thing right here
so i love it because it's near my house
there's nothing better than an audition
in the valley in the valley it's right
here you told me you're doing the radio
show above the chop shop in the valley
this is the best thing ever the valley
is the best i'm on ventura boulevard way
in studio city way before you hit laurel
canyon this is an auditioning place and
it's huge well this is a rare day in l.a
this has to be 15 years ago 10 years ago
it's raining cats and dogs in l.a it's
been raining all [ __ ] day my
audition's 4 15. i walk in there bobby
slayton
the place is [ __ ] packed all right
people are drenched people have nowhere
to stand they got six audition rooms all
of them are packing up in the summer you
could stand outside yeah but here it's
pouring out you got to stand inside
again the shakes just listen to it
all of a sudden there's a little girl a
cute little asian girl
maybe 10.
now here's all these people standing
like [ __ ] immigrants getting shipped
somewhere you know on a ship just
standing there staring at each other
like a subway in new york in the morning
but here's his little girl and her
[ __ ] mother
with a space
maybe ten by eight
with all her head shots on the floor
and the mother's going well you have to
pick it and she's like i don't know and
and people are looking and i'm looking
at this girl and i don't know who to
feel worse for
the girl or her mother they both needed
a [ __ ] smack right
and this is why lee i don't want to when
i did kicking it
all those moms
it was a different game it wasn't about
the kid lee
it was about the mom on shooting day the
fake tits and the fur and how they just
move yeah hoboken and say i'm sorry to
interrupt you no no it's just
and i was thinking about it when bobby i
grew up in a town kind of like yours
and
like the only difference between us is
the way we grew up at all like at all so
like the kid the same kid there with the
mom
and you and me and bobby were all the
same as like a baby so it's all it's all
parenting like i was thinking about it
today because i was my mom sent me a
bunch of gifts and they were all wrapped
inside the box and she called and saying
happy birthday so i was like
i was just thinking about what it
actually takes to like be a parent
and
there are a lot of people like that in
studio city and and i think everywhere
and i think they don't like that woman
probably didn't even realize what she
was doing like she she it did never even
entered her head well you know what a
lot of these parents lived through their
children because they want to be in show
business pistol pete maravich style when
we were kids crystal pete's father used
to beat him and put him in the
garage him up if he didn't score tiger
woods father you know is it true i don't
know
i don't know if he made him play golf
but a lot of parents you know who either
were athletes or actors but i i don't
know how many of them but a lot of them
never became anything but you see more
of those stage mothers and that's the
one thing my wife and i hated i didn't
mind taking natasha to an audition teddy
usually did it my wife but if she was
working i'd be more than happy to take
my daughter and i'd wait outside because
of those horrible horrible parents who
basically you know with the people
you're talking about hi
let's get something straight guys let's
get something very [ __ ] straight
cause ever since i've had my daughter
i've been thinking about this i don't
know if you guys know this i'm not
ashamed to say this
from 0 to 15
i live the spoiled kid bobby slater
i want you to know that
i want you to know that i was born with
a silver [ __ ] spoon in my mouth my
mom gave me whatever i wanted you could
be born with a silver fish in your mouth
whatever the [ __ ] it was you know i was
once my dad died my mom felt worse for
me
so whatever i wanted i got right but my
mom knew how to turn the heat up right
where other mothers just don't know how
to turn the heat up you know i was at
the [ __ ] mall yesterday i told lee
this is how mad i was i called lee on
his [ __ ] birthday and i go lee i just
saw something that really bothered me
and she wasn't mexican she wasn't
russian she wasn't none she was [ __ ]
white white white white [ __ ] no she
was just very just very white she was a
girl she had to be 17.
she had to be tipping the scales
had a mere
three and a quarter no
and this girl had a pretty face
but from the waist down i mean it just
get and she turned around and her ass
didn't even look like an ass that was
fat it looked like a an elephant's ass
at the circus like from behind it was
just mushed up and her feet were worse
than mine and bobby it's not even funny
she was 17.
but in all this appearance she took the
time
to get a nose ring
that was like a [ __ ] african in those
magazines when we were kids and we work
off with the black women from africa
you know and a parent is and i told
somebody and they go your parent can't
tell you that anymore if i walked in my
mom would go can i talk to you
go take a look at your ass
and ask yourself if that [ __ ] horn
that you put your nose is gonna help
your situation that just makes you cool
to attract other people that'll say the
horn is [ __ ] cute i was growing up my
mom wiggle can i talk to you for a
second are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] take
that thing out of your nose and get your
ass to the [ __ ] gym i'm getting rid
of all the [ __ ] sodas i'm get you
know yeah but there's two things you got
to remember number one is she might not
have a mother that was her mother and oh
that was that was her mother with her oh
okay they were together on the elevator
okay because that broke my heart that's
parenting guys yeah that's preventing
parenting you you got to look at your
kid and go i got to stomp with you
uh and the soprano seventh season didn't
the mother tell the kid put the
schnapple back in the refrigerator yeah
yeah okay
you know this wasn't i don't think this
is allowed anymore
uh if there's a way to keep your child
grounded in this business they don't
always listen man you know they don't
listen to you and you'll find that out
you know they do what they want to do i
did what i wanted to do and you did what
you wanted to do if your mother said you
don't smoke pot anymore lose weight
whatever a lot of times that's why we
all grow our hair long i hate your hair
like that what are you a beetle and you
just couldn't no i didn't i wasn't
allowed to grow my hair either was i i
wasn't allowed to have earrings i was
not at my you know in my mother's world
if you put an earring on you were a
[ __ ] and in my mother's world since i
was an only child and my dad died this
would have been the biggest slap in her
face i'm not putting down gay people
listen to the show i'm just telling you
in her world she would stress it on a
[ __ ] daily like i will [ __ ] kill
you
like i will [ __ ] kill you i used to
tell me stories about in cuba how gay
kids their parents would take them shark
hunting and throw them off the boat and
i would [ __ ] sit there and go what
are you talking about i told you guys
the story about my mom when i put a
scarf on in the wintertime i remember
living on dog i grew up on riverside
drive robbie slade then we moved to 205
west 88th street which is beautiful and
then after 73 no it's not somebody sent
me a picture of twitter
88 does it still smells like my dick on
that block that's something you wrote
but then we moved to north bergen which
at that time in 1973
north bergen new jersey was still
considered new york city that's where
people lived when you made money right
when you lived in new york what would
you tell the show oh we moved to jersey
oh my god where in north bergen right
next to ho hope bogan was a dump thing
the city wasn't no hobo well for
gentiles they drink coffee and they go
down there to me i go to hobo and i see
what it used to be right a beautiful
beautiful
old school neighborhood there's still a
couple of great italian restaurants that
will never
ever come back i've been to 10 million
cities in my life and 10 million towns
and the love i used to go to hope i get
goosebumps i get i had a place on ninth
and washington guys that i [ __ ] ran
you understand me and not as a 20 year
old not as a gangster as a [ __ ] 10
year old my friend's dad owned mr big
sandwiches they had it since the 50s guy
don't [ __ ] tell me and we go down
there we'd help him with sheetrock up
the hill
because he bought the building the
benders bought the building in hoboken
in the early 70s you know what that
father sold that for i can imagine you
could just say he bought the whole block
in the 70s so his father used to say you
want a job come to my [ __ ] place and
carry in those days we used to carry
four by eight is sheetrock they sell it
in four by eight sheets we used to carry
four by twelve upstairs as ten-year-olds
in the summer mr bender would give us 25
[ __ ] bucks but it wasn't even about
the 25 bucks it was about the italian
hero he would make us
and while we were eating the sandwich
you tell us about growing up with
sinatra
and how this is where this guy got shot
down the corner he got three blocks down
the corner and he wasn't even italian he
was luther waiting
do you understand me yeah you know
there's still neighborhoods like that
the bronx i still go back to the bronx i
go to new york at least a couple of
times a year and i'll go to the bronx i
have still some favorite pizza places
right i see people see the pictures yeah
you see i i i go to the well you know
one of the east bronx bronx park east
right by the botanical gardens in the
bronx zoo and there's still some really
nice neighborhoods it's good arthur
avenue it's still italian although the
armenians are probably more armenians at
a time but the neighborhood's still
there the neighborhood feel and you
still have some of the old people whose
sons have inherited their little house
remember the movie 29th street with
danny aiello yeah a little [ __ ] you
have your little white picket fence you
have your statue up front the virgin
mary jesus you have your little lawn
it's yours and you hand it down to your
kids a lot of the people have moved away
from that but i just went out to the
west bronx i went to uh ernie louie and
ernie's for pizza you still have those
neighborhoods you know where the cops
still live with the firefighters the
blue collar people there's still some
grandmothers around you know still the
mob guys whoever's left they still live
there their mothers live there their
sisters live there and you see not so
much in little italy in new york but you
have that kind of feel the bronx you
know the south bronx is still [ __ ] fort
apache you know you're so they've never
been able to fix that that's still
shitty uh i you know i haven't been
there but i mean they're they're parts
of the bronx everything's gotten
gentrified and things have you know i
just went to harlem with my wife and you
know it's still harlem there are still
blocks that i didn't walk down but
there's some of it that a lot of you
know gays have moved in white people
have moved in upscale blacks still some
great restaurants i was you know you
know clinton at his office here right by
the apollo theater for a long time i
heard so they've changed a lot of places
hoboken got flooded so bad after katrina
fell a lot of people let me say i have
to say
i'm sorry katrina jesus christ and that
uh that's how bad it was in new orleans
it hit it got him in jersey they got him
in jersey that's how bad that katrina
was so a bunch of neighborhoods have
opened up that would never in brooklyn
like they say brooklyn is completely
different except canarsie is the same
right canarsie is not trained it's a
dump
and williamsburg used to be the most
dangerous place in the world when i was
a kid you know in the 50s williamsburg
and then the hacienda moved in and now
it's all you know you're lucky if if de
niro could afford a place i remember in
the early 90s the sea jews went to war
with the blacks
i mean went to war lee
war the herciness were like [ __ ] you
this is our [ __ ] neighborhood you
want to [ __ ] get rough cop sucker we
invented [ __ ] rough
and they got down there was something
going on in new york the cops had a show
a couple times like a street battle yeah
the seats don't [ __ ] around that's it
they've been there since jesus left
chicago they're not giving up none of
that stuff they don't fight they hire
italians yeah they they're going to get
old they go oh i was going to say that
it's hilarious
with beer
they bring in the puerto ricans they
have diamonds they trade your name one
of the one of the greatest voice
messages i have ever had till this day
was the one you left me on christmas
inviting me to your home wishing me a
merry christmas but you're not probably
picking up the phone because probably
you're back with your family in the
bronx and some two-bed
two-bedroom tournament with 20 puerto
ricans living there i was listening to
this bobby slate and [ __ ] howard but
no
i came out crazy after my mom died
you know i want i'm not gonna lie to you
guys you just don't become crazy i had
the crazy already in me i just needed a
little [ __ ] push
but it goes to show you that i went from
being a very spoiled kid i mean all my
life i had a refrigerator i had a i'm
sorry i had an air conditioner in my
room you know i still remember i still
remember going to my mom and going i
want hbo because the groove tube was
coming on and that tit was ah
and i told my mom i put it together for
a [ __ ] thing but when it came out
well i talked my mom into throwing my
stepdad out i was the final push that
said you got to get rid of this guy and
then she broke his head and then she
goes i'm taking your advice he's gone
i know and i did that to take advantage
because i had it by the balls i could
tell my mom whatever i wanted guys
you know like i said
i got left back in the seventh grade and
sophomore year in high school she still
didn't know i had left back
i could tell my mom whatever i want was
that something i was proud of no i loved
my mom i listened to my mom i respected
my mom she beat the [ __ ] out of me she
spoiled me but like i said she chased me
with a bounty roll on fire she hit me
with a stick she showed up at my
friend's house i was going to jump the
pool and beat me up my mom wasn't no you
know
now johnny come later yeah uh two days
ago
i called the buddy and i was looking at
the date it was july 17th you ever sit
there and go something happened july
17th he would sit there and go what the
[ __ ] happened in my life july 17. yeah
and i called my buddy like you know what
happened july 17th i was in love with
this girl lisa for three years bobby
slade and one day this dumb [ __ ] had a
bar we were just goofing around and i
looked down like you know maybe and she
looked me straight in the face bobby
slayton sophomore year and said i will
never ever date you
you're too close to a friend
you know what telling me never never
never means i'm gonna work extra hard it
took me three years
and like two weeks after we graduated
high school i finally nailed i got some
blow we went back to a house and i knew
the date i was like this is i'm gonna
save this in my mind this is how crazy i
am wow because i waited three years to
bang her three years i worked this
little onion
three [ __ ] years never a date nothing
and one day we were having a
conversation i said let's go out for
dinner she agreed i took the picalissimo
the monday night was lobster for diablo
night for 16.95 in fort leah you kidding
me or what
do you remember that day i took it to
the back of the binghamton where there
used to be a movie theater it was a boat
the binghamton boat you went on and they
served your dinner and you sat on the
boat but there was also two movie
theaters back there i saw 48 hours back
there i saw a ton of movies back there
as a kid i took it back there i had a
package
i had like an eight ball of blow we were
doing a couple lines and we started
swapping spitting i ate a monkey oh my
god it was tremendous i asked if i could
put a coke rock on a monkey and that was
like thursday night friday night we went
out to dinner somewhere and then
saturday went to my buddy of willow's
house and that's night i finally said
let's go back to your place her family
had a house down at lbi
so i took it back to guttenberg new
jersey it's the it's three blocks in
northberg and it's like the [ __ ] true
story and i gave her a stab at six in
the morning i remember walking home
going i cannot believe that was my first
lesson in sticking with something
was giving that girl this man it's great
you remember the day so here's the
beauty of it while i'm talking to him he
goes inspirational stuff how many he
goes how many parties did you go up to
my house a villa my friend asked me this
and i go villas i went to a lot of fun
he used to throw good parties because he
had older brothers do you hear the
comedian no this kid's his name is
stephenville oh he'll be a friend of
mine just when my mother died i hung out
with him he used to have a back shed and
he had a guitar bobby slate and a drum
set in the base and he had an amplifier
and he had a stereo hooked up to it
so we would put on
shattered
and not knowing what we'd do we'd get
all poked up and [ __ ] drinking and it
was just a shed that will always go down
in my soil when i'm in that casket i'm
going to be thinking about that shed
no heat oh by the way no heat
no heat
that's so easy i just no heat just snow
on the ground 20 inches of snow with
light bulbs beers
but the first party i went to was
invitation only my freshman year
the brothers had saw me at the new
barbarian show in april my freshman year
i went to see the stones without mick
jagger stanley clark uh the
watts on the [ __ ] drums the drummer
was still there but the bass but ian
mclachlan was playing the [ __ ] organs
yeah and ronnie woods and i went to this
show and all hell broke loose and on the
way out i saw the avila older brothers
and they were like look at this [ __ ]
guy he's here with you and the younger
villa was there and we all started
talking so the brother had this party in
like july that was the last that was the
first party i got invited to that it was
big time to get invited to those
especially as a [ __ ] freshman you
know there was only four freshmen
invited to this party everybody else was
seniors
so we walk in i didn't do bloating i
smoked dope like an animal i snorted thc
crystal but the brothers were crazy so
what they did was they got a garbage can
and they put a garbage bag over it and
everybody had to bring a bottle and they
put everything in there
they put 50 bottles of booze in there
whatever it was and they put like two
jars of cranberry juice then they threw
a bunch of dead bees in there for flavor
they grew like a hundred dead bees in
there i had no [ __ ] idea terrible and
you had to drink the punch if you went
to the party i was 14 man i was not my
line i'm lying to you i was about 15. i
don't drink bobby slate
in those days they used to drink boons
for them yeah i would split an eight
pack between three of us but i was a pot
smoker oh yeah did you eat the bee
oh [ __ ] yeah you had to eat the beef
that was part of the initiation into the
boys so i [ __ ] drank the like three
of those things guys
the next thing you know i'm getting
[ __ ] woken up and i'm on a front lawn
i'm an anthony sinsulo's front lawn and
i'm getting woken up by this cop named
ray ernesto that when i was in the
eighth grade we used to play basketball
and he always wore colored socks
and he used to drive me crazy when you
have sneakers on it would wear black
socks but he was a good basketball
player and finally i went off on him in
the eighth grade he was a cop and i told
him right you can't keep showing up
[ __ ] colored socks guy you got to
wear sweat socks because if something
happens and your foot gets cut you're
going to die because the ink gets in
your [ __ ] ink that's how [ __ ] i
was and he's like are you stupid or what
but anyway he goes thank you for
reminding me about that that's a funny
joke this is all when i'm 14. about a
month later i'm passed out and who's
waking me up with the cop lights
spinning rayon esto
and he picked me up because what color
were the socks
he had black socks he has police uniform
on he said coco what's going on with
check oh nothing i had too much to drink
he goes come on let me give you it was
six in the morning guys
six i was supposed to be home at maybe
one
and he put me in the cop car and he
drove me home and he walked me up the
stairs i had puke all over my shirt the
whole [ __ ] package he knocked in the
door my mom answered and my mom didn't
even listen to him my mom said thank you
in spanish he just grabbed me by the
shirt and [ __ ] dragged me in and gave
me a couple smacks that was at 15.
do you follow me so i spoiled as i was
bobby slaton yeah i still caught a
[ __ ] beating from time to time you
know my parents
the only date i remember
when i was that young was friday the
13th it was april 1972 and i'm 17 years
old i was selling coke in high school
what i did when i say selling coke not
like
i'd buy
like a what would i buy i don't even
think it would be a full eight ball it
might have it might have been an eight
ball it might have been three and a half
grams and i'd break it up with a half
grams and
it was probably even less it would
probably be i didn't think i even had
that kind of money i think i bought was
more than eight ball sixteenth ball
anyway i'd buy some coke and i remember
getting some coke from some guy and
instead of returning it to him because
it was really horrible horrible you know
right away i would do the profits up i'd
do a half a gram that weekend i go [ __ ]
i got to sell the rest of this because i
owed my dealer whatever it was 100 bucks
that's a lot of money when you're 1750
bucks you know i think i was a busboy in
a restaurant i wasn't making a lot of
money so i'd piss away all my money
gambling at night you know with the with
all the local jews who had money that
was you know they could they would get
allowances of 40 50 bucks anyway so i
sell coke to some girl selling like a 25
package and i knew this stuff was [ __ ]
it was garbage it was like snorting you
know ajax so the next day she comes back
and goes you know i really need some
more and right away they should have set
up a red flag she was a new kid to
school i knew they were trying to bust
some people i knew the greenberg police
department was trying to get me and a
few other guys and like an idiot instead
of realizing maybe this new girl it
didn't even cross my mind she's a cop
you know i sell her a 20 little package
and she wants another package the next
day so i give her another package i
think she calls me up and goes listen
i've got some friends we're going skiing
this weekend can we come by your house
and get another package i'll stop right
right what are we talking about the
other day though they have to make
multiple buys right i was telling you
they just don't make one very seldom
unless they have evidence on you from
something else are you talking about
this about busted you yeah to really
make a case stick on a hand to hand buy
a
d.a will really get you to do two small
buys well they'll bring a witness the
first one was just the girl she brought
two other cops along with her they have
to have another cop we just heard your
word against your word against they have
a tape recorder yeah back then it was no
i don't think they had we're talking
about 19 you know 72. it's not like
there was mission impossible james bond
without all these wires and stuff so she
brought a couple more comps but like i
said like an idiot i should even when
even though he's a dumb seventh year old
you should have set up a red flag right
away you're coming back for more of this
crap how stupid is this bro and she's a
new girl in school we went to a very
small school in westchester there were
700 people that's junior and high school
combined 700 people 7th through 12th
grade so everybody knew each other did
you know each other everybody knew i
knew i don't know that kid but now that
kid's sister i know the kid's brother
everybody it was a big it wasn't that
big of a neighborhood so the fact that
she came to my door and knocked on the
door and i sell solder another package
so anyway a week or two goes by nothing
happens uh seven o'clock in the morning
it was uh
summer of a spring vacation spring break
we were getting ready friday the 13th
we're going the next day my family down
to florida for a week you know to miami
fort lauderdale seven o'clock in the
morning
all of a sudden i'm walking up out of
bed i see these two guys standing over
me you know i don't know what's going on
you know you just wake up you know i
recognize the faces that didn't hit me
right away they were detectives from the
greenbrier police department so my
mother and father are standing by my
bedroom door and the cops start reading
me my rights and i have no idea what's
going on because it was it was probably
a solid two weeks that went by i hadn't
done anything it didn't cross my mind
you know that i sold some coke as it
leaded me out of the house i said look
we're not going to put you in handcuffs
it's the suburbs you know we're not
going to embarrass you just get you know
let's go let's get in the car as we're
walking outside my mother says to one of
the cops what are you arresting him for
and they're selling heroin i've never
done heroin i never sold heroin so i
knew right away this is [ __ ] they
got the wrong guy i get the back seat of
the unmarked car and i said to the guys
what is that all about they said you
sold some coke to an undercover officer
twice like last month remember i said
yeah what do you tell my mother heroin
they said we were just trying to shake
you up and scare the hell out of you
meanwhile they scared my mother so we
get to the white plains courthouse it's
not open yet for the arraignment they
said look we're going to take you out
for coffee you know you're not going to
they take me to the diner they said look
you're a good kid you're trying to run
away from us you know you're [ __ ]
dead i'm not gonna try to run away so
the cops are really great guys you know
they threw me in jail with a couple of
black guys with butter holes in their
side nicest guys in the world
and i'm freaking out here you know
because i did sell coke it was
literally two weeks before nelson
rockefeller the mandatory drug line in
new york state you know mandatory prison
for any kind of drug offense i would
have got to prison if you're 17 years
old or younger i turned 18 in a month
but
17 or younger you go to [ __ ] jail so
the law hasn't been in effect yet so i
get the arraignment my lawyer shows up
one of my father's best friends and the
judge says to my father's lawyer right
away mike we haven't played golf in
weeks right away i see the judge you're
best friends with my with my lawyer yeah
i've been meaning to call you you know
they sometimes they you know anyway they
look they put me out they let me out on
probation i got five years probation i
was a hero in school you know and i
found that who set me up and what am i
gonna do i'm a white jewish kid from the
suburbs let me have this kid killed
but he said he never did it no felony no
it's nothing it was a five-year-old
probation oh my god
that's why i never did any of that
because that would have been me the
first person i sold to would have been
an undercover cop
so
it's just
i when he was telling the story i was
just thinking about weight getting woken
up did you get did you ever get busted
for drugs when you were
i mean you ever get arrested for drugs
when i you know when i was on the run
for a while i would stay at these [ __ ]
up places in new york
and one day i got woken up by detectives
coming to arrest me and it was the worst
feeling in the world really doesn't that
feel like oh to get woken up by the
country
really i put them to the station in
handcuffs and then they came back i
spent the whole day in there they put me
on a lineup then they realized it wasn't
me it was somebody else in the hotel
that made the robbery there was a
shorter guy it wasn't at that time i was
a little built i'd walk around but when
i was a kid
my mother got raided twice
my mother got raided at the bar one time
and how they walk in is it wasn't like
swat today with the swat team and those
days 15 cops would raid your bar with
shields up and then make it was like it
was like a scene the time in jersey was
hilarious because it was they raided us
december 4th i don't know the year
because it was santa barbara's birthday
santa barbara is a huge cuban holiday
december 4th then december 17th so you
start partying december 3rd
at 11 o'clock you start taking the booze
out and lighting candles and people to
blast and people break down emotionally
i prayed to santa barbara in 1954. i
like this holiday i'm gonna celebrate
that my voyage from cuba and santa
barbara came through so now my life is
dedicated to santa barbara and like five
i like three two and i was a kid and i
would hang my mom would make me go to
all the cuban holidays october 8th
september 8th september 6th
uh december 4th and december 17th big
cuban holidays do they have names yeah
they're all saints you all have you have
to celebrate them i start celebrating on
the 8th of september that's my big one
my personal big one then then i don't do
nothing i do the 6th and the 8th you
still do it [ __ ] yeah i still stay up
until midnight who is say saint santa
barbara who was the same barbara is a as
uh
is the same thing
he's in charge of thunder of thunder i'm
finding he has a [ __ ] sword and he
has a [ __ ] horse what do you agree
with what is it zeus [ __ ] choice he's
in charge of nuts he's nuts and you
can't kill animals around him because
they were going to behead him and a
mouse crossed them so there was no there
wasn't that's a real guy that's
catholicism in cuba barbara's a man's
name african well he was also whatever
santeria you do that yes yes you [ __ ]
idiot the chicken head and you and you
play soccer with the head of a goat
another cerveza
you just make up
we don't kick no [ __ ] goats cops i
hate the jews we don't hate the jews
overpriced shitty cigars the better ones
than uh from nicaragua but anyway then
the big one is the 17th that's saint
lazaro that's what is he lightning says
they licked his legs the dogs licked his
legs the he had he was a leper and the
dogs healed them from the leprosy so
that's why you're not allowed to hit
dogs around them it's so it should be
like
you should be worshiping the
dogs it's so relevant in cuba that they
even created like this uh
subculture of this religion of various
different ones but they're all like when
and i'd say michael vick got uh
sentenced to prison right there was 10
federal prisons he couldn't go to
because there was too many cubans there
right they would have chopped them up
why is that because they're the dog
thing dedicated to [ __ ] san lazaro so
they have to dog his [ __ ] faith it's
so
october 8th september 8th is my big one
that's la mercedes who's this guy this
wait wait wait wait wait before you go
how come you don't have him i can maybe
not have him around your neck you have
the dog because it's tough to get him
he's been very you can't get you can't
go in here
i gotta go back to union city what do
you guys feel about the x-men and
fantastic four [ __ ] those [ __ ]
really actually they're real superheroes
what about that man
i think a dog licked his the leopard's
legs and he's a saint oh my god so he
won't give up there like if you have
arthritis in cuba uh we're making
friends with cuba this guy's gonna say
bobby slayton will not be the first
comic to play in cuba listen to me if
you have arthritis yeah or your back
hurts in cuba and you can't heal it
right for a year you wear a purple shirt
any color purple on you you dedicate
your life to saint lazara
fridays you dedicate your life to
helping somebody
you go work with kids or something and
then you for a year you dress up in
purple
and they say your pain goes away it's
very [ __ ] cultural [ __ ] hey every
[ __ ] isn't it every [ __ ]
uh nationality has their own you know uh
yeah the santoria guy that i used to
[ __ ] with in l.a yeah was trying to sell
me santeria like he's like it should
take over that's more history
and one day he showed me a picture of a
[ __ ] jew with a chicken they'd do a
ceremony with a chicken yeah so all
different religions use different types
of you know whatever to use whatever we
just don't listen i grew up in that [ __ ]
it's not like i could
you know i still have memories hey i
laughed a lot too when i was a kid i'm a
comedian a lot of times they they get
the spirits in front of me [ __ ]
hilarious and my mom would bust him
my mom would bust him out my mom would
go to those things just to bust out the
people who would get the spirits in them
so if i see a cuban guy dressed in
purple i went up to him are you feeling
better are you feeling okay is this
helping will you know what i'm talking
about he'd say yeah why do you ask san
lazaro brother because we're a [ __ ]
father
right i'm a follower and he'll look at
you know hug you and those san lazaro
people
i don't know what it is but everybody
who's dedicated to that san lazaro thing
has no problem with [ __ ] chopping
your head off
of course but they love puppies dad
they're part of that whole [ __ ]
manly
you know the sopranos had an episode
about you couldn't eat [ __ ] but there's
a lot of men that believe you there's a
society of men that believe that if you
suck a woman's [ __ ] you'll suck a man's
dick
they don't suck [ __ ] well those people
who believe in san lazaro those guys
don't eat [ __ ] really yeah they don't
eat [ __ ]
so i'm kind of dedicated to saint lazar
but i hate [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying where's tony bennett [ __ ]
break this [ __ ] bobby slayton's
in the house we're gonna get to a little
comedy in a second here look what are
you doing
ready for some popcorn you need some
popcorn no i'm good man i'm not no no no
no no we're going to eat cuban food
after this right yeah let's do this lisa
yeah it's his birthday lisa keep going
keep that kind of [ __ ] away from me did
you get higher give me life did you get
high on it you got to get high i just
50 more than
ah
are we still on here while you play yeah
cannabis popcorn breaker are you [ __ ]
yeah
somebody
turtle who wants to start a podcast
he wants liaison
are we back yet yeah no we're still here
we're just taking a quick high break
uh
joe i was wondering
do you get higher now or when you were a
kid like do you even get that high
anymore
not how i used to get in my 20s and when
i first moved from jersey to colorado in
the early 80s 83 84 that's when i
experienced a different type of [ __ ]
eye that's when i just
i was never a coke guy in the daytime
it always [ __ ] up my day really
listen when you wake up in the morning
if you drink a coke you're gonna be
hungry all day your body craves sugar if
you open up if you wake up out of bed
and as you're pissing you're thinking of
a can of coke and i did it for years i'm
not judging anybody i did it for years i
thought
when i blew up to 418 pounds i got it
because i was drinking the morning i
opened up with a can of coke i can't
recover from that
when you open up when i would do a bump
at two in the afternoon it would ruin my
day because that means i ain't stopping
i said i could always stop i always use
it i mean stopping two o'clock i'm going
until two in the morning really and if i
bump into another fiend like me and we
can we could take this [ __ ] to a
four i used to do that
from 83
to about
97. you're a big guy and you smoke
cigarettes too at that time yeah but i
only smoked from 97
to 2007. because that's when i first met
you we were hanging out i think we
worked together you and i were doing
some lines not a lot of lines but
they're like and then you'd be smoking
you'd even be drinking because probably
because i was drinking you know
you know
you're a kettle you're a cattle guy what
are you what oh a little kettle a little
goose
belvedere little stole if i have to i
was if i'm in miami if i was at that
miami club
my [ __ ] room was across the street
right listen those days i went on the
road to get [ __ ] up there's nothing
like knowing
for three days you're gonna go somewhere
and you're gonna snort three of those
[ __ ] three nights no see i didn't do
that i just did a little i used it as a
tool i do a couple live before the late
show sometime till after and then i'd
wake up in the morning i'd go to the gym
i tried to work out i'd have my little
protein shake no i didn't work out no
yeah i know that no no no no these days
or anything no i still work at now i
know you're dead but no
when i first started going on the road
it was 96
excuse me 97 when i took it seriously i
had moved here
and i used to go on those [ __ ]
michigan runs for yoder and i would go
everywhere you know me in those days for
600 bucks i'd show up 500 bucks you had
to do it the only way you get better
right the only way to improve in this is
to keep [ __ ] going on the road right
and getting [ __ ] you get different
defenses thrown at you yeah and you
learn how to [ __ ] overcome these
defenses and eventually you get money
that's how a comic and as bad as
somebody was it was still better than no
money because i still take gigs now my
wife because it's i'd say this is
horrible money she goes you know if
you're home you're not making any money
oh if it pays an electric bill at a
water bill 150 i remember four sets a
night when you lived in san fran you
first started yeah you did three sets a
night bobby no no that was it was much
different then you played one club i
mean i i didn't
they weren't showcase clubs they were
just regular
one night san francisco was an amazing
town in that respect because i hear
about guys in new york now who you know
you know they don't they're great comics
they don't make a lot of money and they
go well you know if i play new york i
can make 1200 for a week and i go what
they have to do to make that 1200. i
mean last time i played at the gotham of
caroline's i'm playing some club in new
york we do our two shows and whoever was
opening up for me
he said to me i won't see you after the
show i got to get out of here i got to
set i go wait a second you're not on
till midnight he was yeah but then i
gotta get two more sets tonight i go
what do you have because i gotta set at
12 30 in the village then i'm gonna back
up town i got a 1 30 set at the comic
strip and yeah it's 25 bucks here 50
bucks there these guys i mean it's every
night hustling they're trying to pay
their rent well couldn't it be like
joey you went on the road and did all
those gigs it sounds like you could just
move to new york and just do a whole
bunch of gigs in one area like is it is
it how is it well in those days the
money for me was a lot different it's
like now a comic would die let's say you
work helium which i love the club they
don't put up features
right a lot of people can't tell a lot
of features so you have to step and
sleep on my floor like a [ __ ] animal
for a week and i gotta step over and you
gotta smell my [ __ ] oh you know when
you're a comic you bump into other
comics and they let you crash on that
couch and it's great man it's great for
a while it's happening and you really
get to learn about people and you know
people's compassion when you're on the
road and you just put it together man i
used to live on those subway veggie and
cheese sandwiches
i live on those things bobby slade they
hey listen i gave you 500 bucks there
was no the only way i flew
is if i had three weeks
in that town and i would put the three
weeks together in those days babbitt
would give me two weeks at the laptop
i get [ __ ] uh one night in pasadena
another night in conroe and another
night in beaumont i put together 600
bucks then but in those days it was all
going up my nose i went home with
the exact amount i needed for rent and
for two days of survival i thought i had
it tough yeah i went home with what i
needed for rent that week right
and
two days of survival once i got there i
had to go i needed 100 for head shots i
had to pay sag i was section 12 i owed
them [ __ ] 146
it was amazing you know i sit down hey
listen man uh for 18 20 years i [ __ ]
starved like everybody else man movies
and everything you they were hand to
mouth
remember i came when i got here i was
minus 60.
when i got that lay in 1997 guys i was
minus 60. i was minus 20 easy and child
support i was minus 20 in a [ __ ]
attorney fees and i was minus 20 and
bills that wouldn't go away
like you know american express went away
and discover went away but you know a
lot of those [ __ ] hanging
around like aids they don't go nowhere
you know they keep coming back
yeah i had i had i didn't want to go
into it but some major financial crap
going down a couple of years ago after i
lost my room in vegas you know you get
used to living a certain lifestyle you
know people don't say why you're broke i
go i live in la that should be enough
right there you know there's a lot of
guys that will move out of la
which i would love to do i know the day
but you know what between the travel i
need to be near a major airport i'm
flying every week you know i can't be
living in oxnard two hours away from
here you know i can't be living in you
know middle of the country you know
my wife's here my daughter's here so
it's i can kind of kind of made my bed
i'm and you know what as much as i hate
la i want to hate la the bottom line is
when i leave la
i kind of like la i like coming back
here where are you going to go i know
this exactly where am i going to go to
long island and do what walk around like
a penguin for seven months
i go to all these great towns that go
god you know i'd really love to live
here why would you love to live right
now well san francisco is always always
great and right outside of san francisco
is a beautiful town of mill valley
california it's a little enclave you
ever go to mill valley great little
restaurants you know it's very very rich
expensive very very million but you know
what it would drive me up a wall i think
after six months and i talk about living
in manhattan you know manhattan is great
if you have mick jagger and jerry
seinfeld howard stern money where you
know it rains a little bit you get a
private plane go to bermuda it's really
hot you go to house in the hamptons yeah
new york city is the greatest place in
the world but you know what you know i
think that after six months living in
new york on a hot day i wish i was in my
backyard of my pool
i had a freezing day i wish i was in my
backyard under my pool yeah l.a for all
everything's horrible about it you know
i think about leaving every day
then comes the answer where do you go
where do you go where do you go where
and if you have an audition you're gonna
be there you gotta go you gotta you know
listen i have five auditions a year you
know people call me all this i don't
know what's going on well you're 50
50 you're at that age now where
you know are they going to put me on a
show or a [ __ ] dad yeah if the dad's
a criminal or he's been in prison or
something besides i'm not going to be a
dad on the abc family [ __ ] show the
cubans or the [ __ ] off the boat or
[ __ ] nothing but even if you did you
could move back it's not crazy to move
back or anything but then also you know
where i've been like the the past couple
of years it's really nice newport like
down by like laguna and yeah that's
right that's right that's what i want to
do on the witness you know i've been to
my house you [ __ ] are your business
is here your business is here i know but
you're saying you wanted to move no no
no no no i'm talking about leave
somewhere yeah you know i have two years
to make up a decision or for something
to happen to keep me here i have a two
and a half year old daughter that
guys i'm not sold on raising here i'm
not sold
sold or what raising her here i'm not
sold yeah well i'm not sold i'm not sold
and my wife is 50 50. you know my wife
will do it you know it's not that she'll
do anything to go back but listen let's
face it i got no family out here i got a
couple friends they're single they're
comedians you know she needs her cousins
she every time that [ __ ] bubble
guppies comes on about the horses she
puts a hat on and gets a lasso and gets
on a [ __ ] play horse because she went
back to the head on amazon you get a
house back there for 200 grand live like
a [ __ ] doctor and fly out of paducah
it'd be a tough [ __ ] life change but
that covered
that covered ain't nobody gonna drop
obama on paducah isis airport you know
what i'm saying you know it's like you
live in hell out here you don't know
what's gonna happen at that lax
you really don't you really [ __ ]
don't
that's my main place of [ __ ] business
is that what i want eventually the odds
are against you you're going to go in
there one day you ever see those suckers
you ever go home and somebody calls you
goes joey where are you i'm at home why
oh my god thank god they just closed uh
american airlines there's a bomb in
there and they look at tv and they show
a million people waiting outside without
their [ __ ] luggage you can't even
abandon you they just shut the freeway
because there's a car chase they just
shut the other freeway because there's a
forest fire
it's miserable
i would love to live
simple but then again
i don't want it to be raised without
seeing
armenians or russians
or i don't want her to [ __ ] be 18
when they go to new york and your brain
blows up
you know i don't want her to be
sheltered either i want to know what it
is to be rock and roll to walk home that
little black girl next to me the cute
basketball girl that's all county that
girl walks from my house to the [ __ ]
high school past wrecking riverside and
think about riverside past marie etc
that little girl walks every [ __ ] day
sometimes i see it and i want to pull
over but i feel like a [ __ ] pervert
if i ask right right how can i pull over
and that's my neighbor's daughter
they're nice people
so
i you you know you want your daughter to
establish that [ __ ]
where's the how is sacramento i've never
been up there but it's even more
uh
i don't know i don't you know these are
places that you sit there and you
scratch your [ __ ] head and go where
do i really want to go
i'm very comfortable here i'm 50 [ __ ]
three years old i grow my own weed at
this point i'm smoking [ __ ] now i smoke
more than anybody i know because this
[ __ ] ain't working anymore
and be honest if you're gonna be a
normal person with the amount of weed
given to you at shows now you could
probably live on it week to week just in
between gigs
if you were gonna just take it from
there and go home with it
like what about like i
i see like vegas for you
i i've lived everywhere in my mind oh
vegas is
horrendous and in my soul i lived
everywhere right now i want to live
somewhere that
if she walks down the corner i can
[ __ ] rest every morning you know why
i walk mercy to school tuesday wednesday
thursday why because i hate that nate i
hate walking around there i know how
people [ __ ] drive
so i don't rest until my wife calls me
and says hey i'm gonna go to the ymca i
don't [ __ ] rest
i can't write i just pace and i just
said [ __ ] it why sit there let me get
some exercise so i get some sunshine
with the girls i drop her off now and on
the way back it's [ __ ] tremendous
so do you understand one of those
[ __ ] dudes man i know that evil lurks
on every corner oh yes and once you know
that going in it makes your life a lot
[ __ ] easier yeah but it's gone to the
point i don't know if there's a city
anywhere where there's not gonna be evil
i just don't i i want them in a smaller
school you know speaking of evil and
places to go did you hang up that
israeli flag because i was coming in no
that's always been up oh it has out of
respect
for who the flying jew that's who [ __ ]
oh the [ __ ] you think is the only way is
he the flight is he the flying jesus the
flying jew isn't something he's a
regular [ __ ] jew this guy just didn't
show up with our [ __ ] credentials did
he hang out or did you
he did it's mine that's his i lived
there for six months we've had that
since the original podcast that was had
always had to be up dog we represent
here we ain't [ __ ] around we're like
the public enemy of the jews have you
been to israel i lived there for six
months you did yes why
uh because i didn't i applied to emerson
college and they didn't accept me until
the spring semester so i did my uh study
abroad my freshman year how did you like
living in israel
uh i loved it i loved being there the
area wasn't that i lived in like the
desert i lived in bersheva so it was
like oh you were way out there yeah you
weren't even in tel aviv no well no
television isn't really
it's cool but it's like elephant tuna
all right
it's like it could be like new york in
like jerusalem you hear more english and
spanish and stuff in here it used to be
a lot nicer too many jews the whole
neighborhood's gone downhill
but
there's a lot of jews in israel
now where's besheave at it's like
it's it's way out there now it's like a
suburb nice people black people anything
there's um there's a college there which
is where i was and then they had
actually a lot of like nigerians like
all that somebody was telling me they
ate ceviche and tel aviv
that was some of the best ceviche they
ever had
a restaurant from spain do they have
fish tanks yeah israel great fish great
wine that's what the kids said it was
[ __ ] mine it was great
really good restaurants yeah it's good
good and then bourdain was there
and they showed like people getting
bombed like not at the party but they
were eating that's a different part yeah
now tel aviv was like a party place
people tell me it's like new york
toronto it's like
it's like a i don't know it's it's it's
still there's still like is really stuff
there but it's just really
commercial and gendrified and i worked
there last year you know remember i told
you i saw the stones there they were
playing that happens to be the day i day
after i get that the stones are playing
tel aviv and you got tickets of course i
got tickets and uh
and uh is that lipstick it's chapstick
thank you i don't know you were all
[ __ ] caitlin yeah
just like caitlyn um
the thing is if i change my sex thing
you can still call me bobby i just do it
with an eye i don't have to change my
name i got a girl's name boy's name you
know it's i got it it's great to have a
name like bobby or dana or robin but
anyway so i went to israel and leno had
been there a few weeks before doing
something then i called him up and he
goes yeah it's just like the valley you
know a lot of jews a lot of stores it's
like ventura boulevard and you know
it wasn't quite like that but uh yeah it
was a cool place and um
you know that war broke out three days
after i left i don't know if i had
anything to do with that but we played
all those little towns like he's talking
about they do a tour over here the guy
every lieberman they do
get a reclaim general clean gotta do a
half hour and he brings three comics
over they've been doing it for about
eight nine years and the audiences you
think it's gonna be all israelis they're
all expats they're all you know american
jews mostly from new york boston chicago
some from scotland i mean they're all
99.9 maybe more jews and just got to
work clean they love the jew jokes and
it was great it was quite an interesting
experience there's a real big push for
people to move over there and i thought
about it i'm just terrible with hebrew
like i'm terrible learning languages i
mean how many years you've been doing
commenting on bobby almost 40 what year
did you start 77 how much money was
there then a lot of money in common you
know what it's all relative it's you
know if you were
you know i remember
you know it's all relative you know
people
i guess there was always money in show
business i remember you used to read
about you know buddy hacking and rickles
in the 60s making 20 30 40 50 grand a
week he is a stan seriously uh well my
book's almost done it was actually
it's funny it's called raging bully
which is what my wife name of the
[ __ ] cd too yeah well you know it was
going to be called if you can't laugh at
yourself make fun of other people my 40
years and show up as hell because it's
too long of a title yeah so i thought
raging bully uh my 40 years show up as
hell and by the way i've got to call
richard lewis because richard has not
that he came up with he owns that
showbiz hell but he has he always did
that whole you know it was a show from
hell it's from hell so i just want to
have his blessings on the title but
my career has been fine you know i'm not
making a ton of dough i've got i've done
so many pilots but as you know you know
they say jerry seinfeld's story that
pilot almost didn't go it was a you know
brand antarctica put it on because they
had nothing else and and one of the
greatest shows in history television
seinfeld still would have been a giant
star because he was well on his way then
but you just don't know what's going to
go it's not going to go how many great
shows and pilots never made it and how
many [ __ ] shows do you see on tv what
the [ __ ] is this on for you just there's
no rhyme or reason to it really how
lucky are you
i'm lucky i mean
i'm doing great compared to you two but
you know
uh
you know
you know you that's something about
people in show biz they're always
looking at who's doing better and who's
doing you know what it's like somebody
said i'm not wearing a name tag i'm not
saying would you like to try on size
eight and a half you want fries with
that
you know i'll be right back i got to
take my daughter to chemo my wife's in
the hospital you know none of that's
going so you know what when [ __ ] like
that happens you realize how great you
had it so right now i'm about to go out
for dinner get a couple of cervezas i'm
starving by the way we're going for
cuban food that's all i've been thinking
about for the last half hour is when is
he gonna shut up and when can we go eat
i'll tell you i i look at you and i'm
like [ __ ] 40 years
how lucky is that how many people have
quit since you started you know how many
[ __ ] people have quit how many people
have started with you had a little
career tapped out
into somebody made a million dollars and
it's as long as you stuck with it bob i
stuck with it because i had to stick
with it because what else was i going to
do you know i got into a thousand things
well i can have a nervous breakdown
right i couldn't take the road anymore
so i had to slow down but meanwhile the
kids are [ __ ] starving yeah i get it
you know i remember once reading this
article
about ellen degeneres and who i like she
opened up me she started out a lot of
people opened up for me i have a chapter
in my book the chapter's called typhoid
bobby which is uh like typhoid mary who
gave typhoid to people she never had the
disease but she gave it to a lot of
people typhoid mary and she was a
carrier
and i am typhoid bobby i never had the
fame but i have the gene everybody i
come in contact with except for you
becomes a giant star i had jud apatow
roseanne barr i had
david spade rob schneider i had ray
romano a million quicker jon stewart a
million comics greg geraldo million
great comics opened up for me they went
out to greatness
bobby where did you start i saw it in
san francisco i started in 1977 i
started opening for bands and i started
you know but when you're saying you know
i i kept going because you know i
started when the comedy boom was
happening so i got a lot of work you
know i was in the right place at the
right time and i'm sure people have said
this to you
how do you get better the only way to
get better is to keep doing it and it's
hard to keep doing it now because you
know you don't if you're lucky if you
want to start doing stand-up and you
sign up for an open mic night at the
improv or the comedy store or there's
some club that has you want to do your
best five minutes you don't want to
start [ __ ] around so when i started
out there was a comedy night every night
i was a host at the punch line it was a
house emcee so i i didn't see the shows
for leno for seinfeld for george wallace
michael keaton kim badada elaine bosler
so i got a lot of stage time and bill
graham had the old waldorf next door and
there were bands to open up for there
was ray charles before thompson
temptations warren zevon and there were
guys like dana carvey robin williams
harry gone on to do mork and mindy and
there were a lot of guys you know
remember pollock and dana would open up
for pablo cruz to the beach boys at the
amphitheater none of that was easy but
when the stranglers came to town or
their dictators came to town or mink
deville or the tubes some new punk rock
band who are you going to call the
original ghostbuster call slayton
nobody's going to take 50 bucks to open
up for that goddamn band so i'd go open
for a band that's why we kind of became
the pit bull of comedy because somebody
for a man you never did well i mean yeah
you i i shouldn't say that i would do
fine but when you're a young comic it's
not how well you do it's like riding
that mechanical bull how long can you
stay on you better start for 15 minutes
if you want your 35 dollars i would stay
on i'd do my time and i became better
and better and better at doing it you
know i got a little name for myself in
the bay area someone opened up for ray
charles or warren zibon what if his
adults you know they weren't there to
see me but they were they'd listen to
you they'd give you a shot and then it
opened up for the rock bands and you
know maybe a george thoroughgood it was
a little bit tougher so you know and
then you emcee a show opening up for the
big shots it got tougher and tougher and
then easier and easier because you just
had to keep doing it so that's where i
cut my shot i got a lot of stage time as
an opening act you know i went from
house mc to feature act to headliner and
the bay area at the time had a ton
that we had they had three or four
full-time comedy clubs they had three or
four maybe five
you know one-nighters you can make it a
living and then i realized he can't keep
playing the bay area every night you
know dana carvey and kevin pollock
started getting into movies i said i got
to get on the road so you go to zadie's
chicago go to the cleveland comedy club
then hilarity's in in in cleveland then
you go to the other punch line in
atlanta you know then a few improvs
opened up around the country there
weren't that many clubs but you make a
living in the bay area and then you
start branching out to all these clubs
and then the comedy boom really hit and
there was plenty of work out there you
know for a time you know there was
always four or five comedy clubs in
vegas and if you're really clean you
open up for frank sinatra i share it you
know you become paul provence jerry
seinfeld those guys all opened up for
those people i couldn't do it because i
wasn't clean enough but the point was
there was a lot of work for everybody
you know there were game shows and hosts
and sitcoms and a lot of [ __ ] passed me
by and when you know it's funny because
i'm sure this happened to you when that
stuff did come up you know bobby i have
an audition for you well i'm leaving
this morning to the funny bone in
columbus you know and you couldn't just
put yourself on tape there were no
iphones and you couldn't just go down
the street to the armenian guy for 20
bucks hey he's got a little uh you know
av outfit so i go [ __ ] it they'll have
to wait till like
or how many times i can't tell you how
many times because i suck at auditions
i'd go in i'd be proud of myself i do a
great audition for a show they want to
see a friday well they can't see me
friday because i'm on the road my
manager would go and back then it wasn't
that difficult you can catch a plane
from san francisco you can fly right
back down and fly back up again so yeah
it sounds really easy hop on a plane and
fly down but even when tickets were
cheap i still got to pay 75 to get to
the airport i saw you get on that plane
i'm gonna get to l.a i gotta rent the
car i gotta fly back i gotta hope i make
it in time the airport's not closed
because of fog and all of a sudden with
me 400 [ __ ] dollars to audition for a
part you're not really right for me no
and you know what happened with all the
traveling and all the movement and all
the stress yeah yeah yeah all right you
should have sucked exactly sucks exactly
i did it three or four times like a pig
never your nose wide open and one day i
said i'm not doing this if i'm in town
i'm in town one time one time i got a
call
as i landed in sacramento right thursday
i was like are you [ __ ] serious but
it was for my name is earl
and it was friday at 11 o'clock
so you got on a plane with that [ __ ]
yeah it was perfect for me i cannot miss
that i'm going in front of the
producer's one-shot deal how long ago
were you gonna leave the airport huh did
you leave the airport i mean no i was i
was already in the hotel in sacramento
okay so i worked thursday night i
finished i went in i studied the [ __ ]
lines i cut it up a couple different
ways i didn't do any blow
i didn't do any blow that night and i
[ __ ] jumped on a plane at like
[ __ ] eight in the morning and i flew
into burbank and
uh went that was up here and i went in
there and i you know i was arrested how
long ago was that
this had to be 2017. you know okay well
now and even back then now you want to
do that and you want to get on and buy
an airline ticket it's like 150 bucks
this way no it was hard this was it was
like 82 dollars but i already had the
plane ticket home so i just changed
the i did a [ __ ] tremendous move that
time by the way
i did a tremendous move
the lady didn't like me at the punchline
at the time
she didn't [ __ ] like me guys
she didn't like anybody they finally got
rid of her you know that bro that i
don't remember i don't remember there's
so many different people right so she
didn't like me i got up there one time
with rogan
and she didn't like me i got up there
one time i'm with a bunch of comments oh
there was one moment in sacramento yeah
she was horrible and i went up there
this thursday and i went in there like a
man i go listen i got a problem tomorrow
i got to fly back to l.a
and she just started going off on me
guys
like what the [ __ ] do you think this is
i hate these hollywood [ __ ] wannabe
comics and i didn't say none i bit my
tongue i didn't say dick i just said you
know what man i ain't coming back
you weren't making much money anyway no
i was making a hundred and a quarter
right and they wanted to headline me
with gene pompa and i'm like i don't
want to do this and you know what
happened
i [ __ ] get off the [ __ ] plane as
i'm getting off the plane i got a call
from rogan ari had an audition for
something and he couldn't take the plane
in time to go to san francisco he was
doing carbs for the weekend
and ari had to cancel on friday morning
grogan called me goes where are you at
he goes i'm in burger
i'm going to audition for my name is
earl
i went to my name is earl
booked it in the room i could tell i
booked it they were looking for
criminals
there was like stealing i went in there
booked it on the way out he had called
rogan's manager and they said go to
burbank airport there's a ticket waiting
for you to san francisco you're all
going to fly in together
i even went home to hollywood and took a
shower and got different clothes and
everything but that was a once in a
lifetime you're right there was there
was one time i had to get off a plane
i was in miami and out of coming monday
at 11 i had been snorting for a week
straight bobby slate and that sunday
didn't like i had decided since thursday
for monday morning i snorted all weekend
and ate some mass and i didn't go over
my [ __ ] sides and getting off the
plane and still being a little drowsy
and running up to the audition and you
walk in and there's 60 people in the
room and now you haven't slept in two
days and every minute that goes by
you're getting worse right i know the
[ __ ] deal so it sucks you know i used
to try to kill i'll never forget when i
was shooting analyze this what do you
think i did
what do you think joey diaz did it
and otherwise yes i booked classicals
oh
i booked rascals right like a [ __ ]
galvon that i am i booked rascals in
jersey yes so i went i was shooting in
jersey i was shooting tuesday and
wednesday
okay
wednesday is when rascal started in
those days it was wednesday night then
we cut the tuesday out
and oh maybe it was a tuesday it was a
tuesday because i went there monday yeah
and then no worries and i asked the
director who was cool as [ __ ]
how long he was the scene's going to go
great
scene's going to go fast well de niro's
in the room he wants you to shoot from
every angle
so you shoot from 12 o'clock 2 4 6 8 10
and both sides his sides and my side
this is a [ __ ] nightmare holy [ __ ] so
this scene started at nine in the
morning at six
we're still there
and it's the scene where i'm getting
shot
and i'm not i can't even think about the
lines anymore guys i had set him 200
times already it was me and anthony
lompogo i couldn't say the lines anymore
and all i kept thinking about
was that [ __ ] feature spot bobby
slater oh yeah yeah and i couldn't focus
i couldn't focus on the on the [ __ ]
line it finally came out after an hour
like they were getting pissed off at me
and everything
embarrassing
and then i redeemed myself with
something else and it was all forgotten
but
oh my god did you make it to rascals
[ __ ] yeah you didn't hand
yeah yeah
how do you guys did this like decide to
like
manage your two two because you have two
careers what can you have to book
stand-up gigs far in advance but then
acting gigs are kind of they can pop up
whenever but they know in stand-up gigs
that you're going to cancel you know
they know and i've only done that a few
times i don't get many acting gigs but
they're well aware you know i always
hated these guys they do this a lot i
remember uh
they'd be showing hollywood squares or
something some comic would call a club
and go i just got hollywood squares
today uh they want me you know so i
gotta cancel and i think you know you
could do that show anytime or whatever
show it was they want me for this show
or that show but if it's a show you do
an auntie cancel on a club who you know
see i've always tried not to do that
because that's been my the clubs are my
bread and butter you know my managers
are excited to be cancelling you should
go read for this and i'd done that
before and pissed off the club took me
forever to get back then to go read for
something natalie not get it not right
for the part you know it just and you
know they just it's just you know just
jacking you off forever on this [ __ ]
so it's like the clubs are my bread and
butter and there's been a lot of times
where i just won't cancel a gig to go
read for something unless i'm sure yeah
quentin tarantino called he's a big fan
it's a big move well okay then whatever
you want me to do i'll kill my firstborn
i'll be there in an hour but you know to
go read for some [ __ ] sitcom which
probably won't go some horrible part you
know it's just i don't i don't care
anymore i had a manager that revolved
around that at the time i liked him
and
from 2001 to 2006 basically this is how
it went down i would book your comedy
room
but i'll tell you what if i got a call
for an audition
it was over
i would cancel it doesn't matter what
the audition was even if you're not
right
if it was a home run for me yeah
the thing got canceled that's
understandable it was got cancer right
and but i learned later on in life that
again there was one time i had to cancel
somewhere those people still don't talk
to me i was gonna say i mean people can
understand one time but
i'm sure these people move around these
bookers move around between clubs so if
you piss off the same person two three
times they might not book you i had a
one time i tried to cancel on sarah nine
that [ __ ] muscled me bobby slade oh she
yeah yeah she was like she [ __ ] can't
she goes if you don't get on the plane
and i woke up the next morning i said
[ __ ] you i'm not getting on the phone i
never liked her and then she booked me
anyway again for new year's so [ __ ] up
she robbed me but she booked me again so
someone to re you know sometimes i was i
was brought up
in the sense that if you had something
with comedy clubs that they understood
they understood number one because
that's part of the business you're here
to do television and number two that
sometimes you have to cancel on them
especially i'm saying just a little i
mean i remember a particular story
uh
and god bless his soul
bobby
robert schimmel
robert schimmel worked the improvs and
this is 2001 2002 maybe 2000. and
something happened in this country
reality shows
and it was how to marry some [ __ ]
homo or how to marry some [ __ ] pole
smoker or some [ __ ] and guess who won
some comedians you know some comedian
who used to open up with is it hot in
here on my pants on fire he used to set
his pants on fire like the cufflink on
his pants on fire
so
the guy wins this on fox he's the
struggling comic guys
and
guess what the improvs do because
they'll suck your dick they don't give a
[ __ ] they canceled robert schimel on
wednesdays and thursdays
and made him cancel wednesdays and
thursdays because they were bringing
[ __ ] harvey homo in who was the
husband of the year on some show right
do you remember what this guy's name was
he was on a white dude and he lived like
in the beach like hermosa beach he
started and i had worked with him at
harvey's one time
and somebody told me this guy was huge
this guy was going to be a star but
something went wrong his show went down
i still remember working all right we'll
show you who you thought about i still
remember working with craig shoemaker in
1999 and they called me to the other
room and they said do us a favor don't
piss this guy off he's the next tim
allen
this guy's got more network deals than
anybody he's the next tim allen please
do not piss him off
and nothing happened with craig
schumacher yeah he worked a lot craig
always i mean over the years as a
stand-up but they were booking him as
the next [ __ ] tim allen right he's no
[ __ ] tim allen that was my boy you
don't remember the other guy you're
talking about no so this guy wins this
[ __ ] reality show rick rockwell rick
rockwell that [ __ ] mobile
the
millionaire before the wife the
millionaire guy who turned up your whole
big scam there robert schimmel
two weeks
what he would do to get back at the
improv for that is cancel the weekend
but he would cancel it on friday morning
but i didn't care because guess who
covered from ah i used to feature so now
i became the headline i was already in
town i didn't nobody came to see me but
what the [ __ ] i would practice
headlining i was terrible but it didn't
matter right but my point was robert
schimmel would cancel friday morning
at eight in the [ __ ] morning they
would call me like friday 8 30. how
often did that happen
he did it to me one time there and one
time in tempe and that's how i knew he
did it on purpose he did it on friday
morning
i was scheduled to work on two weekends
like two weeks apart three weeks apart
and he canceled both those gigs on a
friday [ __ ] morning glad he had the
money going yes god did he follow me
yeah you [ __ ] with me i [ __ ] back with
you you keep him everybody gets on point
it's hysterical they treat you like [ __ ]
the improvs
or any comedy club for that matter until
they see you
on a commercial
or on some stupid tv show
you know it was so funny like somebody
came up to me they go joey i heard you
say uh one night that this town doesn't
start working for you to book a
commercial he goes that happened to me
he goes some club booker in ontario at
the improv saw me in a commercial and
now i'm an emcee there [ __ ] once a
month that [ __ ] doesn't make any
difference anymore though it it doesn't
but in their minds
you might become something if they see
you in that case i don't think it works
that way anymore you never know how a
person's perception is free from you
yeah listen bobby slayton uh
okay
how many [ __ ] shitty comments do you
know that they get put in a movie
oh and now they go on the comic tour oh
absolutely they're terrible they don't
have even 30 minutes i was talking about
that with my jiu-jitsu teacher this
month with mike with john evans we were
talking about
guys who get put out there way before
this time
uh you know i don't know i can't even
figure people out but it's like guys
from a reality show saturday night live
alums they're like i could do this stand
up [ __ ] on the [ __ ] road oh yeah and
they get on the road and after two weeks
they got to call pablo francisco or some
other guy to come in and do a little
longer yeah because they're cutting that
time back for 20 minutes and 10 or 20 of
the q and a now
yeah yeah because everybody thinks they
could do this and so you know it's in
internet sensations too they they do
something on the internet for three four
minutes these clubs are telling me
they're selling out you see they've got
one show that it was a horrendous
nightmare that chelsea handler show in
the afternoon that horrible show all
these comics have big gay [ __ ] gab
fest that chelsea handler show oh it was
it was horrible but you find that there
were some really good comics on the show
you're laughing like what would you you
enjoyed watching chelsea handler show
you liked it joey
i love watching his shoes she always
wore sexy shoes she's what
she always wore very sexy shoes
i wouldn't [ __ ] her shoes but no but
there were a lot of comics
some of them know some great comic but
there was some because of that the same
thing about movies you know you see them
on a on a talk show and they have a few
funny lines and they're hysterical for
five ten minutes and all of a sudden
they're headlining and selling out
because of that show
to her credit to their credit i mean hey
whatever it takes to make a living
whatever it takes it's great i mean if
if i was on that show and i was a
mediocre comic and i had ten minutes and
they wanted to pay me three four five
thousand i would find a way to do an
hour i'd bring out puppets and guitars
and i'd do a q a and whatever you know
if is a man when when this podcast stuff
started happening and people started
coming out to the shows i was already
doing comedy 19 years
i wasn't quite a headliner but i could
cover the spread i was a lot better than
50 of the people you saw
i had you know i had faced audiences i
put my [ __ ] work in here right it's
not like some guy that hits a tv show
and his agent goes hey man they're
offering you 25 grand a weekend to go on
the [ __ ] road right and you're going
to get them once or twice
you're going to get them once or twice
after that they're going to say i can't
go see that that was horrendous he was
up there singing songs and although
people keep going back to see paulie
short explain that to me go ahead
explain it to me
paulie i'm an expert sure i'll explain
to you why i understand i moved to los
angeles yeah and since day one and i've
been doing comedy people always ask me
has mitzi senior yet
you know and i used to see this kid on
[ __ ] mtv or whatever the [ __ ] it is
back in whatever [ __ ] year it is
bobby
you know and i go to the store and i
meet him and
i'm not crazy about bobby or whatever
his [ __ ] name is at the time paulie
but i don't want him there wasn't the
time bobby paulie whatever his [ __ ]
name at the time you know he was still a
little semi-famous when i moved to l.a
right everybody had attitude and people
who worked for him had attitude and i
had beef with one of them and paulie
came to me so it was always a rugged but
he always knew i loved his mom
he always knew that if i was in the room
i had no beef with mitchy shaw
and over the years whatever happened i
was there the night they threatened
rogan and i was there i turned my back
because i thought rogan was going to
knock him out
but rogan was smart and he walked out
and they ended up banning them and i
would see paul you always had a wise
remark
and about a year ago not even i started
going back to the store bobby slate and
after six weeks you know when you don't
remember somebody
you have somebody in your life who's
just out of mind man they just they're
one of those people that did kind of you
18 years ago and one day they just
stopped coming to the punch line yeah
and then they show up after 10 years and
you're like what the [ __ ] happened oh my
god
and even you feel bad you're like oh my
god i forgot all about this guy existed
right that's how i saw paulie shaw and
he came home and he gave me a hug and we
started talking
and it's been a very how are you related
what's going on what time are you on 10
30. good to see you man all right
and last week i was at the store and i'm
laying against our [ __ ] freezer and
he walks in and gets a water and he goes
how are you and i go good and he stands
there for a minute bobby slate
and i'm sitting and i look at him and i
go oh my god
first of all i'm in my 50s
and i'm at the [ __ ] comedy store and
i got a spot at 10 45
okay and i'm looking at this [ __ ]
good look in front of me
and i'm thinking to myself i grew up
when i first started comedy he was
already on tv
so at that moment for some reason which
i never again i got nostalgic
i got it
it's like someday
lead paid and i'm not making fun of you
i'm just saying something from your
upbringing we paid how much did you pay
for thankful tickets
in college
i would i know i i think i paid a
hundred each okay what ticket for the
bank
junior i was a junior in high school
high school okay i took my prom date
okay so you took your prom date
you really thought he was funny you
bought his albums you know lee whatever
conversation we're having here he was a
part of who you are right now you're at
this [ __ ] table because you went to
see dane cook
because you were you liked comedy his
first two albums come on listen to me
man listen to where i'm going with this
i had never like i
i've always liked stand up and that's
like the
kind of stand-up like
my mom would drop with driving would all
listen to like his his albums were like
fine for her to listen to and that like
i didn't like you it's kind of like you
find out you're not supposed to like
them now most people will be you know
it's like who buys britney spears first
down
obviously you didn't and you [ __ ]
didn't but she sold 80 million copies
okay somebody's buying these arms right
now those people find those albums going
what the [ __ ] was i thinking but guess
what when they're 60 they're gonna look
back and that's a part of who you are in
a way he's part of it for some people
he's like the [ __ ] beatles right
first time they saw a brother-in-law
they jerked off into their girlfriend's
mouth in the eighth grade something
people attached themselves to something
so i get when paulie shaw goes to a city
right and he could still sell 550
tickets
for him
that's great you know chicks still go
how many chicks were in love with paulie
shaw when they were 20. now they go see
him and he looks like a [ __ ] bus at
him and that's the end of that they're
like i wasn't going to suck his dick i
was thinking of sucking his dick so i
got that i love my husband we'll see how
powerful it is like but that that's the
entire thing that's going on with cosby
that's the only reason he's not like
being beaten in the streets who
cosby
he was part of so many people's lives
yeah he's like everyone loves them
so it's like oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
i thought you were like he was a part of
it that show was insane
everyone watched that show it's like
michael jackson yeah michael jackson
well listen
when you talk to mike michael jackson in
my ears we were talking about starting a
podcast what i had to go backwards the
first time i bought when i came from
cuba was abc then i bought james brown
then i bought whatever get your yaya's
out but those that's the first time my
first album was i think before the
beatles no
well no the beatles and then the monkeys
here are two later one of my first help
i still like the monkeys
but they
good [ __ ] let me do some shout outs and
hold
were
we'll abandon [ __ ] we'll give you some
wait when you after you do the shout
outs we'll we'll be here for almost two
hours can we go eat i'm starving that's
why i'm doing a [ __ ] shout out scott
sucker so we go get something deep but i
gotta find my glasses oh my god i can't
see you can't see that they're right
here on the table the id glasses aren't
to be able to see your glasses see what
i'm saying i wear my full time now you
have to
uh jeremy grug i love you dom de niro we
have good life i love you too dapadan 90
alexander voigt aaron ray zach motor nfc
and robert cole robert colon you bad
[ __ ] by the way before i forget
before you go on you know your show the
last time i did a phone in with you yes
and i've done
100 podcasts a lot i got more people
following me on twitter when i say a lot
of people i mean another 10. that's a
lot for me i have 8 000 people i lose
every time i tweet something i lose more
people every time i make a joke i'll be
having i'll have negative i'll be the
first one to have negative 200 followers
if i keep going at this rate but pit
bull of comedy
like you're a [ __ ] savage after
you're doing your show people
these the shout outs these are these are
my people too
i gotta talk to you while lee is here
one of the things i stress about this
show and lee will be here with me the
reason why you're on here bobby slate is
because
i learn from guys like you you know i
learned from watching guys i could tell
i learned like from watching mitch
hedberg i learned from you guys
it'd be a sh it'd be really funny to see
what mitch would be doing today
because everybody would know about mitch
and these kids wouldn't be jumping on
the bandwagon or whatever but
the real interesting thing is comedians
come and go and it's and the sad thing
is that
uh the clubs take a certain time of the
year that's dark and they offer you that
week and they pay the lowest money they
can get away with of course and they
make it seem like they're doing you a
favor and people just don't go because
they're not excited because
they don't know and it's it's it's like
anything else in this business
uh i don't listen to aerosmith anymore i
haven't bought an album in 20 since done
with mirrors yeah but guess what they're
still making music
and it's good do i [ __ ] am i going to
buy it tomorrow no you you've evolved
you've been doing comedy for 45 and i
like to think get better you're getting
better and funnier so for somebody not
to say listen i like bobby slayton's in
town this guy is in town no no let's go
see uh neil chid he's on e
keeping up with the kardashians they rap
you know and this is where people make
mistakes they get and then they go in
and
they look at the bill they drop 90 and
they'll never go see this [ __ ] mud
again but meanwhile they'll pay the
small 15 for you and they'll laugh their
ass
and you know and you know they're back
there you know you're just the [ __ ]
guy that's been doing comedy i deserve
and this is what bothers me this is why
uh people come up to me like it's
amazing that you've involved with social
media well he's helped me out so bad at
it and but there's nothing to be bad
about it's what we do for a living on a
natural we look for things that are
[ __ ] awkward and put them on there
you just can't put them on there you
gotta let people know you're a
warm-hearted [ __ ] but hold on
one second i go for a [ __ ] with an ice
cube sucking my [ __ ] you follow me
there's always somewhere that's it
people want to know what's really in
your thoughts
am i am i like i know you're right and
you know what i'm thinking about before
i forget i want to do this with the next
time i play you know i'm not working at
the south point in las vegas they
actually let me play the showroom and
the last time i played there i brought
jackie bartley stuttering show i
remember from the stirring show with
that leno show but this time i'm
bringing in lenny clark and jim
florentine it's bobby slain and friends
because i know i can't sell out tolerant
when you play that you do the show
for the mexican you do the midnight show
right no no i do the regular weekend
but you do it in the big showroom yeah
it's a beautiful round it's a beautiful
room i'm taking my specialties
i want to take a special there too
september 20th i am taping a [ __ ]
special
at the south point [ __ ] casino
on a saturday night yeah i'm going in
the end of august i wish next time i
play well if you you know you already
headlined maybe we'll do a thing
together have a raffle and we're going
to give away [ __ ] tickets in a hotel
room and you get to eat 500 milligrams
of [ __ ] oh [ __ ] milligrams with
[ __ ] lee siyat
on friday night the 19th after the first
show well keep
so i'm a big supporter of this what's
your point
what is the date that you're there with
lenny clark let me break down who lenny
clark is okay
one of the reasons i'm here is because
of this gentleman here but also a man by
the name of lenny clark wales out of
boston who i saw him on the rodney
dangerfield special remember the reason
why i wore a suit
for my first two years of comedy was
because of lenny i never went on graves
without a suit and you've got jimmy
florentino i just worked with at the
store saturday night oh was he he was a
[ __ ] pisser i love jimmy that station
that he does the music i don't lie to
you that metal midgets i listen to it
every sunday
it is he told the story about going to
see iron maiden and judas priests at
asbury park i went to that show and for
a long time in those years i go to shows
and somebody was lighting [ __ ]
uh
the smoke bombs
and he told the story about getting high
and lighting the smoke bomb and they
knew it was him and they threw him out
and he kind of called his mother to pick
him up and his mother seen his red eyes
and she's like but you're getting high
and he's like no no no no no it was the
smoke from the [ __ ] i was dying that
was a part of my youth he was he's great
did you see him on uh the finale i think
it was the finale of the louis ck show
no oh he oh he well he dies on it but
he's really good having a fight with
louie over fart jokes
and uh
it was just he was saying the story i
gotta go keep saying the story and talk
more about stop one let me go shoot this
you gotta wait wait i gotta pee what are
you oh you have to pee yeah i'll go pete
and i'll close up the show while you're
okay well hurry up because i
oh great now i have to talk to you about
your birthday sure you know for the last
we've been on now i don't want you how
much you can add this down to almost two
hours there's no editing i've had no
editing nope i've had to pee for a solid
half hour and i kept thinking every time
i gotta pee
he's gonna end the show but no he's got
to do something else but while he's in
the bathroom you know have you been out
to uh vegas
yeah i go a bunch
i went
headline a couple months ago and then i
guess in september or august we're going
out no september oh that's what he's
taking a special yeah you know what's
great about the south point and that's
really cool it's off the strip and when
you go to the strip you know locals
don't want to go to the strip the strip
is horrible you know you got it's
getting worse and worse and worse you
know i don't get dressed up when you go
to a four-star restaurant i don't want a
guy coming in with a dirty t-shirt and
flip-flops you know at least if you're
going to be white trash pig
at least wear a clean t-shirt you know
you go and you see the whole strip it's
become and the locals don't want to go
there because the crowds and the traffic
and the drunks the homeless people dress
up like spider-man you know the street
performers are they homeless no but they
might as well be they're always out
there but
probably some of them are i mean if
you're going to be on the strip dressed
up as wonder woman or minnie mouse what
a great job for a homeless person you're
going to be out there anyway begging for
money [ __ ] like a cartoon
character so they don't arrest you you
know
um but anyway so the subway is great
because it's off the strip but it gets a
lot of locals i like this other point
really important you thought about the
some point i was off the strip right
always really nice i really like the
stop point i have a great time there
it's real people it's a big room what's
the dates when you're there august 21
through 23rd but lenny clark you know
had his own show lenny on cbs remember
that lenny clark you should be awesome
that's donald i wrote show that used to
be a flight show who the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with dog i don't know
rescue me when i got into [ __ ] comedy
i got into comedy lenny was on the john
lennoquet show and i would sit there and
learn from him for a while he was the
fat guy i learned on [ __ ] jackie
gleason so lenny and jackie to me were
in that same cousins of families so
i tried to emulate them i saw lenny lee
is later at the store and i pulled him
aside and i told him my story and you
know what he was very [ __ ] cool to me
so great guy i love you guys and that's
why they're working with me all right so
can we go eat now what are you doing
shout outs let me [ __ ] do my thing if
you're doing this then i can go pee now
i got to do the sponsors i just want to
say something real so you say thank me
now let me make a good brother i need to
keep it in there it's either this key or
the other silver one that looks just
like why do i know there's gonna be a
dead hooker in there hurry up hurry up
hurry up let me read this three get out
of here go go do i gotta tell the
[ __ ] church people something real
important guess who contacted me this
weekend lucy snowbush
how [ __ ] funny is that crew a friend
of a friend of a friend she said she
went to a fellow express store to mail
the boxes and the guy said lucy
snowbrush are you from north bergen
and she goes this has happened like 15
[ __ ] dimes to me
so how you like them there apple and she
finally reached out she's like number
five she's like she reached out to a
friend of a friend of a friend and they
got back to me and this is what we're
gonna do so i'm gonna try to give her a
call tomorrow and uh
say hello and see if we can have a call
in and
just talk to us
how you doing brother happy birthday
thank you very much happy birthday
you've uh
you've grown up to uh you've really
[ __ ] grown up in front of me how old
were you when i met your 23
[ __ ] close that door wait i can't the
bathroom i can't get the bathroom door
open the male bathroom i use the member
i got it i got i got
one of them you give me the right key
[ __ ] podcast here
i thought maybe there's somebody in
there use that key right there maybe
there is who knows and the mail one the
first
let's do it let's get out of here stop
interrupting [ __ ]
anyway close the door
i forgot what we were saying
anyway
thanks like a happy birthday
um
probably like 22
23. five years i got a girlfriend now
you're wearing your pimp shirt brand new
uh-huh you the mother-in-law cooked for
you last night mom sent you how much of
a check she put in that guy sucking he
hold the knot on me
no no no no no you're [ __ ] stuttering
[ __ ] how much you give you i know she
gave me the small five grand this is my
buddy she gave me that [ __ ] hanukkah
money from 1929
they were holding on to it and [ __ ]
ah
anyway we gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
man i love that you guys listen to us on
a monday afternoon uh first spots are
always up to my my [ __ ] life blood on
it
always on it
always with the [ __ ] nootropics alpha
brain
money back guarantee coming at you
nobody does that we don't even want the
[ __ ] product back besides that you
got the testosterone upgrade and your
body you have the
the teas about coconut oil they're
putting your coffee and whatnot it never
ends with on and they're always getting
the head of the head and the head and
the head so do me a favor go to
honda.com right now take a look at their
website i can't help you out with the
[ __ ] ropes and the weights but i can
help you out with the supplements so go
to honor right now and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 off your first order you got
to be more enthusiastically you know
what i'm saying is a church what is it
it's church yeah
like you put two shroom techs in your
[ __ ] all right number two nailed it
life.com i love these guys my men peter
and david always putting it together for
you guys it's nailed it life there's
lost groomies or monoz.com they got 15
[ __ ] names what do you expect that
cuban but dave and peter the best vaper
pen out there in the market you know you
get 20 off when you go through us 100
guarantee you call them if you have a
problem i think you can put wax in there
and [ __ ] trees whatever the [ __ ] the
lingo is
oil and wax there you go [ __ ] who
takes care you like uncle joey go to
naildonlight.com and press in joey diaz
boom and get 20 off your first order so
the pen's 50 you get it for 40. the
small 40. what i'm saying you should
always be paying 45 but i negotiate it
down for you an extra five points number
three hit e6
5 for 50 last longer taste better last
longer 1200 guaranteed pops you
understand me that's like a hooker with
a [ __ ] big ass mouth that's 1200 you
go to one of these sevens and elevens
what do you [ __ ] get you get three
pups for [ __ ] eight dollars we're
giving you five over the
small amount relax 1200 [ __ ]
relax [ __ ] sucker 1200 guaranteed hits
hit e6 that's how we do it over there go
to 86.com right now and get five so you
get two cigars and you get three
different [ __ ] cigarettes and their
taste they got the fruits raspberry
coconut whatever [ __ ] flavors you
like almond whatever you like cocktail
then you got cigarettes you got 24
milligrams 16 milligram eight zip
milligram and zero you got to pick three
out of the four all right don't break my
balls go to 86.com right now and press
in joey's church boom and get five for
50. tell them we sent you they'll take
good care of you maybe they'll throw in
some extra [ __ ] in the box number my
main man dave foley
doing it tough let me iron dragon tv
kung fu movies to the hill if you love
the chinese people flying through the
air this is the website for you roku
correct hd what is this don't just drag
[ __ ]
what what's up what are they pressing
joey joey and get two free movies
downloaded on the arm i'd like to thank
bobby slayton
don't forget august 21st and 22nd at the
south point casino i will be there
taping a special only you [ __ ]
know right now september 19th or 20th to
saturday night also this week in chicago
thursday and friday and rosemont
saturday and then next wednesday night
ice house for uh combination testicle
testament slash
podcast and then august 14th
and august 15th i'm in toronto at the
comedy bar
uh the fifth no the 15th of the uh
podcast seminar and the 14th is at that
weed place
where the underground
when you get high so that's going to be
a live flying radio and what are you
going to do when they [ __ ] stab you
down then when they give you 8 000
milligrams
because i got a team of people yeah
it'll be high as [ __ ] giving your cakes
they're going to spray thc powder and
your [ __ ] hairdo
it's all over they're going to put a
thousand milligrams in your head doing
it let's do it all right
i love you guys don't don't like this
please go onto twitter what is it and
just go to my twitter and the link's in
my mind yeah go on the [ __ ] twitter
all right bobby slate now can we eat now
we're going to eat i love you guys stay
black yeah something for bobby slate put
your earphones on all right